wie es bei dir die neue bei mir ist die
lage sehr entspannt das sind sessel in
denen man sich ein wenig zurücklegen ist
die lage phänomenal aber du hast gerade
album rausgebracht machtwechsel gehst
auf tour
wie ist die lage so sehr gut ich schon
jetzt 25 ersten wie dieses liegt er
jetzt schon ein bisschen was zu rücken
sechs wochen oder so wir haben 120
erreichten gut gestartet in der sehr
starken woche wünscht man sagen ich war
einer der stärksten wochen bis jetzt im
jahr
jetzt steht die erste solotour an wir
haben uns ein bisschen klein gehalten
ich bin jetzt fünf sechs konzerte im
april werden auch weitere fünf sechs
konzerte spielen dann irgendwann im
september oktober
und ja ich bin guter dinge dass wir uns
jetzt langsam langsam immer weiter
aufbauen 12 13
auf der straße wegen raps nachts james
mercer denn was hat auf mich einen james
damals um 12 13 jährigen zu suchen es
doch wohl nur gekifft und gesoffen und
gekocht wird und ja ich war unterwegs
und ich wollte das machen und ich hab
kriege zu hause geführt
und irgendwann hat musik halt auch
wirklich stein gebracht dass ich auch
persönlich mit meinem leben wenn eine
gewisse waren gerutscht wäre ich
eigentlich in die hätte landen müssen
von zu hause aus ja ich habe auch einen
älteren bruder
gott sei dank auf den vernünftigen weg
ist jetzt bald sein medizinstudium
beendet ich bin auch sehr stolz auf ihn
und bei mir ist es halt anders gelaufen
am ende des tages sind meine freunde
auch alles männer die erwachsen sind und
für sich selber stehen und deren sich
für diesen weg entschieden und ich
respektiere das auch wenn sich jemand
für diesen weg entscheidet wenn es
vernünftig macht nicht wie ein kleiner
kleiner junge wer rausgeht und auf
einmal aufgrund irgendein
minderwertigkeitskomplex ein gangster
sein will
wenn sie sagen das ist unser ding wir
wollen das machen dann macht es okay no
risk no fun
aber trage die konsequenzen wenn es
genannt so ist das wenn du im knast
landes heilig wie eine posse würde jetzt
sagen wenn es wenn du draußen den dicken
muss und dinge macht und jemand muss
seiner familie was passiert häufig okay
heute aber so sagt er warum besteht weil
du hast dich für diesen weg entschieden
und wer sich für diesen weg entscheiden
kann der kann halt als ich 16 jahre alt
war das auch ein guter freund von mir
damals mit meinem cousin zufällig bin
ich einfach nicht raus gegangen sie sind
auch irgendwo rumgelaufen wollten was
weiß ich auf einem spielplatz und
scheint brauchen also ist streit
entstanden mit irgendjemanden und jemand
den ich damals mit kantaten messer
gezogen und den wenigen abgestochen es
an dem tag für zwölf jahren haft
gelandet und das bis heute auch noch
nicht aus dem gefängnis raus das mit
meiner eigenen inhaftierung und auch die
taten nicht davor begangen habe ich war
damals halt auch eine zeitlang im jahr
2009 wo ich schon als web aktiv war
nachdem ich mit casey babbel schon ein
album release hatte damals offiziell im
handel und dann irgendwie komplett
abgedriftet gar keine musik mehr gemacht
hat hatte ich auch eine zeit wo ich sehr
aggressiv war so ein typ mann damals
geld geschuldet hat und ich etwas sehr
schlimmes mit ihm gemacht habe so
daraufhin gab es seit dieser
auseinandersetzung
forum mülheim an der ruhr wo auf mich
geschossen wurde
es sind viele dinge passiert die mich
einfach dahin gebracht haben dass ich
gesagt habe wenn du dass dir selber und
deiner familie antun und muss durch
überhaupt bei dem können und auch bei
dem hintergrund den hass weil sie so ich
habe ein gewisses köpfchen mit herz auf
der straße gibt es viele menschen die
auch wirklich skrupellos handeln und die
einer von diesem komplex gruppe losen
war ich nehme dann immer jemand der sein
herz am rechten fleck bewahrt so sein
glauben bewahrt hat und ich habe mich
einfach irgendwann hatte stein
entwickelt werden jetzt wenn ich jetzt
album rausbringen wo ich sogar ein paar
straßen rapper dizzee und sage dass ich
kotzen bei euch ist das ist daraus
entstanden dass ich dann abgeschoben
habe als ich gesehen habe dass ich halt
so eine base im deutschen hiphop
entwickelt hat das auf einmal so alle 14
bis 16 jährigen kann angefangen haben
web zu hören und aber gar nichts mit
dieser musik voll zu tun gehabt haben
das einfach nur als plattform sehen und
bei facebook irgendwelche leute zu
beleidigen und das total nur noch das
war einfach alles nur noch stumpf und
ich habe gesehen um für mich war diese
musik halt immer mehr gewesen
ja ich mache immer noch straßenrap so
weil viele leute verwechseln das jetzt
manche konnten zum beispiel nicht
verstehen dass ich irgendwelche newcomer
rappern wie 145 oder kunde oder so
probst gebe auf mein recht ich feiere
sowas immer noch meetings und ich mache
es auch zum teil noch selber mir ging es
halt wirklich darum dass ein gewisses
mit ihr und eine gewisse base die daraus
entstanden ist geht mir auf den sack
das macht das alles real alles im rahmen
ich berichte ich erzähle dinge aus
meinem leben ich mache auch gerne dinge
die bisher positive laune machen
mittlerweile und nach vorne gehen und
ich erzähle auch von der straße aber
alles halt wie gesagt im rahmen gutes
stichwort
das hoffen wir mal dass alles im rahmen
bleibt ok